Well I read you
the part of the First
Amendment called me to say the absolute Bill of Rights.
I did not say that our entire Bill of Rights is an
absolute I said the absolute
right to have a man were to say this to me out on the
street town Rasho make
no respecting an establishment of religion.
That's the First Amendment.
I would think a man Congress should
have unless they destine know the meaning of words.
That's what they mean to me. Certainly they mean that literally.
And I see no reason to attribute any less
meaning and they would have had then I would have
known they might not have that meaning now because of
the general idea that it can mean or absolute Anyway I don't agree to
that they wanted to mark boundaries because there were some things they did
not
want government to have the power to
do and whether some things they didn't feel that way or
that they felt that they should have how to do it within what they call
reasonable
limit the Fourth
Amendment the right of the
people to be secure and persons houses papers and
effects against unreasonable searches and
seizures as soon as they had want to make all searches and
seizures
illegal so that no government could ever have a
say search and seizure. They would have said so but there is an
unreasonable and you turn on down term in moderate
it says excessive bail shall. We
require it says excessive and the people who wrote
it knew the dead not set specific boundaries.
I subscribe to the
doctrine that the fearsome
in which. No person shall be
compelled to be a witness against
himself means that no person shall be compelled to be a
witness against himself.
Now the theory has been the fact that that's
bad and unlawful Constitution prevents it is not
because it interferes a man.
Well if it's not because it's in the First Amendment. Where does it come
from is it the mind of the
judge in other words is he going to fix limits to the Constitution.
I don't see that I don't think I have that power and I would know
that I don't claim any right to keep the Constitution up to date.
I was just anal orders contribution. Hours battling
against in
real what you thought it was your obligation to sustain them because they work hard to do
I don't think it's both which I think it's
an obligation to take this country too should I don't care what anybody else
has decided. Actually mean to
you our system of government puts different people on the
course people with different views.
I think it's that they're now trying to read these words silly as it may
sound to some people some people have said that I'm either
unable
to because if our if I were
not. Dishonest. I couldn't say that
they're absolute.
Well I just don't agree with them I think I can
and as a justice I would think you'd know the Constitution
by heart.
Why do you always carry that. Look at
the Constitution I don't know about.
I can my memory is not that good.
When I say something about it I want to quote it precisely.
So I use it. Karen a pocket.
Mr Justice. Most Americans understand the
Constitution and I think most of them do
know I think most sure they
do better than the court. People don't know I get
letters all the time and I get
many people who don't have a good idea
of
grama they're certainly not good
writers and they're all telling me that you ought to get off the court and.
Go to
Russia will back to Russia
well.
They think they know
it and that idea is all the same you can trace it to the
same thing and make it what it
is what they experience.
It's all because each one of the leaders that the
Constitution prohibits that. Which they think should be prohibited and permits
that which they think should be permitted.
I don't think because it says a member the Supreme Court has to be a lawyer.
There are possibly.
I
don't know.
I'm not sure that you should have all of
this because if you're going to have a government.
You've got to have somebody that knows something about the basic brick of
it but I see no reason why.
I don't see fine wine as day. Socrates would have been a great
judge had even of hundred
one later.
Not
that we don't know how many good
minds.
Today in America the same today the liar that you would
think would be a good justice.
He said
it knows a great deal about it. There's a million
and many same time
many suggest you raise the point that sometimes
are indicated. Sometimes.
To legalize the legal approach.
Now suppose it were to find in some cases which you were
considering that there was a difference between what you thought was say
or what the heart says and what the law
provides How would you
decide the law
provided just that.
Actually yet you
see I have always written
out that the
object is to have a written constitution.
I would follow exactly what I thought it said at the time and I wouldn't
try to amend. Third I believe in the division of the
three branches.
Would you ever reach beyond the law judges ever
do on that it do they do.
One basic thing about the desire for the bill the
right one great urge a great many people really.
Natural
low natural law concept some I'm put it on a
religious basis. Some put it on a phone call
basis a natural law contract. I just want
to watch best under some people. Language today is the
most nice and. We do to a custom another
government and someone conceived the idea
that due process of law meant.
According to fan is
decent and they began to write to that
effect Of course I spend my idea that that's
not what it
means because that would it does it would do
something that I'm not fought I don't believe the Constitution provides
that is it would permit the judicial
branch of government which is only to interpret the
Constitution
and to write it on DAY TO DAY. And months to
month and year to year.
What best fits the time. That's a very prevalent for last.
I'm not sure what it's the controlling the life and list government.
Lawyers a concern for the government is
concerned you don't feel that the judges should judge according to what the
Times
know haha. How would they
know jumpers and ask if there's the other one or trust just
one
man and one man can certainly not sense what's right.
Gosh you know better than no
money.